guys I'm Greg I'm Greg - Greg and Greg -
are gonna watch the extended trailer for
our easily
arguably my number one one most
anticipated movie of 2017 fifty shades
darker are you ready are you ready I'm
ready if you're ready I'm excited I'm a
horse
who are you already I don't use that
word in years weird word horny yeah we
use it in years it sounds kind of but
how do you do when you tell the woman
that you're turned on I don't use I
don't say hi I'm your English girls
never hits you up like hey I'm horny you
want to play no come with me all right
not in so many words as feels like as
your trailer leaked up so much should I
sleep have dinner with me okay fine I'll
have dinner with you
I hope the scene plays out that surely
[Music]
be quick admit yes are you happy
oh he's changing good this is like
lovely this time no rules no punishments
you really hear the emotion in her voice
and then our secrets not about shooting
you love God John oh oh yeah oh yeah I
washed your hair you know that girl oh
[ __ ] oh oh like a different turn watch
look you're the first woman she's tried
to say what do you wants anymore I want
this to turn into a collateral
Oh audience ordering as a reputation do
you wanna be
respect interesting god she's like
didn't good to help a deal I could never
forgive myself
tell me what you have that I do none of
those people are gonna die and waited
our John Deere have chills nipple chills
uh-huh cuz I'm so pulled in to
everything that's happening why are you
all dime all about this D let's just go
to the theaters buckle this is boy
campout and fun and then we get inside
look at the perfect seats we'll [ __ ] on
them yeah then we'll recline the seats
and cottage again this the theaters just
gonna be full of people [ __ ] just no
one's watching that would actually be
great I think like that would be like
you as a success of this book that would
be the cure to society is just everybody
goes to see it and then slowly but
surely one by one every movie theater
just everyone starts having sex with
each other
and then everyone leaves happy and just
slowly the world gets much happier Fifty
Shades of Grey that the movies a success
of everyone's bomi yeah they will tear
down barriers people come together and
then come together yeah and then you
know their own shell out it's perfect
you know you just wait a minute what
what do you see that name at the top of
the credits Michael De Luca productions
know the music Danny Elfman Danny Elfman
did the music music to the first film
wait a minute what the [ __ ] hey maybe
what that's gonna be a really whimsical
score yeah it's right there 50 shades of
grey well maybe I did maybe after that
age of Ultron and that's a detail I saw
during the first movie and promptly
forgotten oh that's pretty surprising
attended three he does this every night
like he'll pop up every once in a while
and like a completely non genre place
and just be like this is a score did I I
can't trust the trailer anymore
especially when they released like three
or four because they tend to have like
two that are kind of similar in tone and
then they do one where it's a totally
different tone
this was a super different tone because
of the
song they had it felt more like a be
happy like for most of the trailer had
that time like everything's going good
this is a rom-com now not like a sexy
erotic thriller I'm a little sick
so I took time like I have a list of 90s
movies I want to catch up on oh cool I
didn't start with Shawshank Redemption
I didn't start with Forrest Gump I
started with basic in singing whoo now
that is a sure good erotic thriller
that's a good erotic thriller that is
sexy and violent and disturbing but
you're turned off you're like I don't
know if I should return all right out of
the bad might happen
she's like really half-assed version
which is a bummer since I feel like as
long as we're gonna return to the
romantic thriller genre it should be a
good one it should be an erotic
suspenseful movie these are weird movies
I was watching this trailer and like I
couldn't help but think this just feel
like an airport IMAX movie like actually
the same way that the book is kind of an
airport novel it's like everything is
kind of sweeping and beautiful but it's
all like I want to watch this on an
airplane I'm really wondering how that
two elements are going to play out cuz
you got all trailers have defined the
two main plot elements of Anastasia and
Christian are gonna get back together
rekindle the romance do some nice stuff
finger banger in the elevator and stuff
like that and then there's this other
plot where Christians passes like who
the [ __ ] is this anesthesia what'd she
have tonight oh yeah and then there's
like a helicopter crashing and guns in
the jungle like I don't I'm just
wondering like how exactly is this movie
gonna play out are they gonna like cut
back and forth between building up with
Christian Grey's past coming back to
haunt her or is he gonna be like a
Midway shift where everything's just
going great you know like the [ __ ]
save the cat be cheap or just fun and
games the whole time and everything's
going rippin the midpoint when
everything seems all fine and dandy
coming into that the bad guys are gonna
close it no I yeah I have no idea I
wonder if they're just trying to cast as
wide a net as possible just be like hey
ladies it's got the same like you know
Fupa and romance erotic stuff yeah you
love from the first book but also hey
fellas check it out this chicks gonna
straight-up kill him maybe that's gonna
be cool look John I don't know here's
what I know
Valentine's Day 2017 I'm conflicted do i
watch fifty shades darker or John wick
chapter two um whichever one you choose
will drastically determine the course
fury if I don't have a Valentine which I
currently don't know you need to see fit
you need to see Fifty Shades alone if
you don't John wick too with a date
Valentine that is the only acceptable
only single guy in the theater alone
yeah she's 50 shades darker yes looking
around get center seat I'll get like the
very front row where I could put my feet
out yeah
that when people walk past me there's a
guy right there I have with a bunch of
crunching popcorn just watching Nick
just shades of gray like the when I went
that like the audience was very specific
it was the most eccentric crap seeing a
long time and all the different kinds of
people but I would probably go see that
movie anyway just cuz like the first one
had this weird I don't know why I wanted
to see it there I gotta check this out
for some reason I don't know if I'm
quite as interested in checking this out
but half of me is like well super maybe
I'll go check maybe I'll go continue I'm
totally watch this no matter what hey
hey if you're new to the channel the
chain you you you you I'm looking right
at right at subscribe right John is
reason scenario you're going Instagram
someone's about it no one do 11 just
gonna do the rap guevara Eminem super
eager yes but let me go if you echo did
exactly someone I'm gonna be a studies
old I'm just in case genres reasons
Jerry on Twitter and Instagram social
media manager of facebook.com slash blue
house in the real rejects Jon's give a
quick shout out Jenny g90 she donated
8,000 bars to us last 30 days of you now
Jenny G night
listen Jenny I don't know how old you
are underage or overage careful - 70
years old we are gonna go watch fifty
shades darker together my dear if you
don't live in California buy a ticket
we're going and I'll pay hey Fross I'll
pay for the movie ticket we can split
the popcorn we get the large we get a
free refills it'll be a great date we'll
watch 50 shades darker and if you're
like 19 or older maybe I'll let you be
fortunate enough to kiss me on the cheek
cuz I don't put out on the first date
not that kind of man
matter how hot you are Jenny and I will
sit in the row behind you guys like your
dad or something please I'm like a first
date please and I keep a little out of
control I will be monitoring the
perimeter at all times